writer-director Richard Linklater's 1993
film Dazed and Confused is considered to
be a cult classic the ultimate and
somber film this high school comedy
featured a host of up-and-coming actors
and in the 20-something years since it
arrived in theaters some of those kids
have grown up to become a less
celebrities while others have faded into
obscurity he is what the cast of Dazed
and Confused looks like today Nicky cats
in a movie filled with cool and lovable
characters Nicky cats Clint Bruno stands
apart as one who's downright scary and
thanks to his intimidating turn into
angry alpha male actor Nicky cats has
faced some typecasting over the years he
told IGN I mean everyone says what the
bad guys are the most fun but I've
definitely gone through streaks where
that's all people wanted me to play the
bad guy especially after dazed and
confused nevertheless cat has managed to
carve out a pretty impressive career and
have kept in touch with some of his
Dazed and Confused comrades among
countless other roles he's played a
pretty awful guy in the Matthew
McConaughey movie a time to kill joined
up with Richard Linklater for suburbia
and even starred in Adam Goldberg's 1998
indie film scotch and milk
apparently he's forgiven the guy for
slugging him in the nose Jason London if
you had to pick a main character in
Dazed and Confused it's a football star
Rando Pink Floyd played by Jason London
at first it seemed like London was
poised for stardom but the a this life
has eluded the axis so far after Dazed
and Confused London showed up in a
series of little scene features
made-for-tv movies and TV shows like
Tales from the Crypt
as far as big roles go he was the
leading man in the rage chari to the
critically derided a necessary sequel to
Brian De Palma's horror classic Anthony
Rapp one of the smartest guys in school
Tony Olsen is the poker-playing
intellectual with really weird dreams
about Abraham Lincoln actor Anthony Rafa
got his start in the Elizabeth Shue
comedy adventures in babysitting later
on they deplane six degrees of
separation appear in TV shows like the
x-files
and reunited days done confused
star Adam Goldberg as one of Russell
Crowe's buddies and A Beautiful Mind
however ruff is best known for his work
on Broadway
the Illinois born actor starred with
idina menzel in the 2014 show if then
and for the country and Little Shop of
Horrors and of course rap was one of the
original actors in the Tony
award-winning musical Rent even
appearing in the 2005 movie adaptation
the actor also made headlines in late
2016 when it was announced to be playing
lieutenant Stamets and Star Trek
discovering the first character and a
long-running franchise originally
created to be gay Rory Cochrane
everybody's favorite stoner Ron Slater
is one of the most iconic characters and
Richard Linklater's entire filmography
the long-haired pothead stole the show
and that's 100% thanks to Rory Cochrane
the only guy you could ever convince you
that George Washington was involved in
an alien cult this wasn't the last time
Cochrane would play a space felt hippie
for Linklater in 2006 the actor showed
up as a junkie in a Scanner Darkly
he also played a doors quoting biker
alongside his future wife Renee
Zellweger in Empire Records and he later
joined up for the CSI Miami playing the
part of Tim Speidel a trace evidence and
impressions expert he wasn't too big on
proper gun maintenance more recently
he's popped up in a smattering of
high-profile movies like Public Enemies
Argo and black mass Marissa Ribisi the
brains behind the every other decade
theory Cynthia Dunn spends most of her
time hanging out with a fellow nerds
Mikan Tony she'd a lot more laid-back
than the rest of her trio and by the end
of the film she's got plans to check out
an Aerosmith concert the twin sister of
actor Giovanni Ribisi Marisa has
continued to pop up in TV shows like
friends and grace under fire she hasn't
done a lot of acting since 2003 but in
2008 Ribisi teamed up with severe bangs
to form a Whitley cross a fashion line
that showed up in the likes of Vogue and
Elle Ribisi is also a busy woman having
two kids of the musician Beck Adam
Goldberg the snarky is character in
Dazed and Confused Mike Newhouse played
by Adam Goldberg is the wisecracking
senior who punches a bully in the face
Goldberg went on to have one of the most
successful careers of anyone involved
with Dazed and Confused consider his
filmography a Beautiful Mind Saving
Private Ryan waking life these are just
a few of the films rounding out his
resume but Goldberg is also equally
comfortable appearing on TV shows like
Entourage ABC the short-lived cop comedy
the unusual and even as a nutty roommate
and Friends in addition to acting
Goldberg has directed four of his own
movies and he's released three albums
oddly enough Goldberg isn't all that
enamored with the role of Mike Newhouse
he told the Fox that he considers his
performance to be some of his worse
acting ever considering it was only his
third feature film he's probably being a
bit hard on himself
Wylie Wiggins whether he's trying to
escape from a gang of padel wielding
seniors or get it on with an older girl
Mitch Kramer as the kid were all
cheering on and in that role is Austin
resident Wylie Wiggins who's made an
interesting life for himself in the
years since dazed and confused he shown
up in a couple of small films but his
next biggest role was when he signed up
for another Richard Linklater flick
waking life Wiggins hasn't done any
professional acting since 2013 instead
he makes his living in the tech world
he's also big into the indie gaming
scene helping to found a video game
collective known as wagos rancheros
created in 2011 the group hosts an
annual Austin festival called fantastic
arcade and operates an arcade and art
space known as a Museum of human
amusements Parker Posey Time magazine
named her the queen of the Indies but
before Parker Posey became a darling of
the indie scene she terrified freshman
students of Starla Marx the meanest girl
in school
of course prior to landing the role of
dollar Posey was a regular on the soap
opera as the world turns
later on she appeared in the cult
classic party girl and Richard Linklater
in suburbia but while she's had a few
mainstream roles here and there like Lex
Luthor's Marlin Superman Returns
she's probably best known for her
collaborations with improv
extraordinaire Christopher guest
starring in four of his films Posey fans
to keep an eye out for Netflix his
upcoming lost in space series in which
actress will play dr. Smith a
gender-bending take on the classic
character Kristin inaho sir
after being publicly humiliated and
slathered with condiments
Sabrina Davis spent a restful evening
proving she's more mature than her 14
years might otherwise indicate her
real-life counterpart Kristin in a
holster as a similarly impressive
attitude only instead of hanging out
with the cool kids
she spends her time helping those who
are far less fortunate inaho sir
appeared in a few more projects after
Dazed and Confused like the TV show
clueless and the made-for-tv movie a
computer wore tennis shoes
however inaho so quickly grew bored with
acting as she explained to the Third
Coast press in 2005 I was doing silly TV
movies and sitcom work with the type of
work I was doing I knew it wasn't that
great at it and there wasn't being of
any use to this planet I loved inspired
to do something more she became involved
with the anti-war group called the
American Friends Service Committee
coordinating a multimedia exhibit called
eyes wide open beyond fear which
displayed a pair of boots for every
American soldier killed in Iraq as
recently as 2013
inaho sir worked as a director of
philanthropy for solidarity bridge a
group that provides medical equipment
for people in Bolivia and Paraguay Milla
Jovovich
one of the biggest stars to come out of
Dazed and Confused Milla Jovovich left a
lasting impression as Michelle the
guitar strumming stoner perhaps more
than anyone else dazed and confused had
a direct impact on Jovovich his life a
16 year old married her 20 year old
co-star Sean Andrews and the couple
remain hitched for a grand total of two
months before dazed and confused she
scandalized audiences in return to the
Blue Lagoon and as she stole the
spotlight as lilo in the Fifth Element
but if you're at all familiar with
zombie flicks then you're well aware
that Jovovich is best known for her role
as the toughest nails alice from the
Resident Evil franchise Jovovich has
also worked as an official spokesmodel
for L'Oreal started her own fashion line
and even made a name for herself in the
music industry as for her acting career
she's far from done Ben Affleck maybe
he's a good guy to have blocking for you
but Fred O'Banion is a
kind of person you love to hate and
that's all thanks to Batman himself Ben
Affleck it's no secret what he's up to
today he may have had a show business
fart appearing in Burger King
commercials but after beating up on
Wylie Wiggins a select continued
struggling in the film industry
until finally winning an Oscar for
co-writing Good Will Hunting with that
statuette in hand the actor went on to
star in blockbusters like Armageddon and
Pearl Harbor Affleck turned his career
around after starring in bombs like
daredevil and G Lee by stepping behind
the camera directing movies such as Gone
Baby Gone
and the oscar-winning Argo and of course
he's also been done in Bruce Wayne's
cape and cowl and mercilessly beating
anyone unlucky enough to get in his way
hey that kind of sounds like fair
o'banion Matthew McConaughey a list
actor Matthew McConaughey keeps getting
older but David Wooderson stays the same
age
really McConaughey doesn't need an
introduction but even though he's been
in terms of films what his son is still
his most memorable character since then
McConaughey has become a major Hollywood
player starting off in films like
contact and a time to kill before
charming it up in a series of rom-coms
like the wedding planner and failure to
launch
more recently the actor has been wowing
critics and audiences the light in roles
and true detective and a Dallas buyers
club in other words it seems a man is
doing pretty okay or as he'd say it
alright alright alright thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're looking
to